[Musica]
la prima volta che ho sentito un suono
strano nella testa come un ticchettio un
tic toc
ero a dubai stavo lavorando in
un'agenzia di pubblicità
era il 2007 e stava organizzando un
evento uno di quegli eventi cura dubai
appena esplosa 1.500 persone
arrivavamo da tre giorni di lavoro
intenso e io avevo praticamente finito
quindi era nel dietro le quinte della
cena di gala tavoli imbanditi
sedie vestite centrotavola floreali luci
alle pareti e dal dietro le quinte vedo
questo esercito di camerieri decine e
decine tutti i vestiti uguali che si
muovono come una coreografia come una
danza e portano in sala questi cibi
perfetti buonissimi questi piatti
fantastici alcuni ospiti un po di ospiti
avevano deciso di fare altro quella sera
quindi le cucine avevano cucinato per
1.500 persone e quindi questo esercito
di camerieri portava il cibo e alcuni di
loro tornavano col cibo intatto in
cucina io guardavo la scena e stavo allo
spreco allo spreco di cibo di tempo di
impegno di risorse e 2012 e ho sentito
di nuovo un ticchettio nella testa
ero in senegal e non in ferie in un
viaggio di turismo responsabile
la cena si faceva tutti insieme intorno
a dei grandi piatti di metallo dove ci
si metteva intorno circa 5 6 persone per
piatto e non si iniziava mai a mangiare
se tutte le persone che dovevano essere
sedute non erano sedute e si controllava
anche che ognuno avesse la stessa
quantità di cibo non si lasciava nulla
certo a rischia di pesce l'osso di pollo
ma non un pezzo di carne non un
pezzettino di verdura ma neanche il
granello di riso
poi dopo a turno si lavava questi piatti
enormi e alcune volte certo dice vabbè
non abbiamo però in realtà era perfetto
in quei giorni il ticchettio nella mia
testa era
costante era praticamente esplosivo
io sentivo il tempo che passava avevo 34
anni e pensavo che avevo dedicato
tantissimo tempo un lavoro che ho amato
e adorato e che serve per comunicare
vendere raccontare prodotti vendere
prodotti che poi magari qualcuno spreca
e in quel momento il ticchettio e un po
esploso e il 2015 e inverno sono in
vacanza non ho dovuto chiedere ferie mi
sono licenziato
ho scelto un progetto un progetto di con
un socio per una casa di produzione
video e posso scegliere i progetti su
cui lavorare
se c'è un progetto che mi interessa lo
seguiamo in iran faceva caldo ma ero
raffredda tissima cercavo sempre un bar
dove bere un the caldo che io imbottito
di paracetamolo che mi serviva sempre si
veniva sempre servito con quei dolcetti
meravigliosi quelli fatti con pistacchio
e lo zucchero che si sfalda in bocca con
me c'è una signora di roma
chiacchierando mi dice che suo figlio
con alcuni amici aperto una onlus che si
occupa di recuperare le eccedenze
alimentari dagli eventi verso le mense
per i senzatetto
mi dice sai mediamente spesso capita che
si sprechi molto cibo lo so le dico non
sapevo che si potesse recuperare mi dice
sì si può così può portare
alle mense i ragazzi lo fanno e su roma
funziona molto bene lo dico guarda se
per caso vogliono pensare di portare il
progetto torino
fammi chiamare magari posso dare una
mano
un anno dopo e gennaio sono in un centro
congressi
qui a torino non sto lavorando sono con
tre mie amiche tre socie tre donne che
con cui abbiamo deciso di apportare a
torino la onlus dei ragazzi di roma
entriamo in cucina ci accoglie lo chef
che ci dice abbiamo appena finito la
cena di gala su 600 persone e 100 non si
sono presentate e ci porta su questo
tavolo dove c'erano dei filetti di
fassone io ho sempre visto la fettina
del filetto quella che magari mangia al
ristorante piuttosto che trovo nei
pranzi di famiglia ma un filetto intero
non avevo mai visto e soprattutto non
avevo mai visti
12 in fila praticamente la granduchi
dividere a metà per metterli nelle
vaschette e portarli via
e insieme a quello abbiamo portato anche
ovviamente tutto quello che vi potete
immaginare essere il cibo di una cena di
gala in piemonte agnolotti e altre cose
era sabato sera il giorno dopo la
domenica sera mi chiama la direttrice
della mensa per i senzatetto a cui
avevamo donato il cibo e mi dice grazie
perché oggi a pranzo per i nostri ospiti
è stata una festa perché non sono non
siamo abituati ad avere questo tipo di
carne questa qualità di carne da servire
ai trans da quel ritiro ad oggi io i
volontari che lavorano su questo
progetto abbiamo ritirato di tutto dalle
torte premiate di pasticceri triplo
cioccolato quelle specchianti
piuttosto che quest'estate c'è stato un
grosso concerto di un famoso cantante
dove il pubblico non era poi così
numeroso 15 hanno donato 300 panini che
abbiamo dovuto smaltire su quattro mense
e poi pane il pane in ogni ritiro c'è
sempre il pane
abbiamo dovuto prendere dei sacchi da
fornaio per portare via al pane e pane
normalmente viene sempre già donato cioè
ogni panettiere lo porta alla mensa o
alla parrocchia perché il pane e sacro
il pane e il cibo fondamentale pensando
un po con amici compagni di avventura
anche loro
usciti dal magico mondo della pubblicità
abbiamo pensato perché non proviamo a
fare un progetto di economia circolare
economia circolare questa parola che si
sente tanto in questo periodo
vuol dire prendere un oggetto e
trasformarla in qualcos'altro con il
pane si può fare la birra è una cosa che
esiste si può fare abbiamo provato per
scherzo a recuperare il pane ea fare la
birra è in questo momento siamo in in
vendita scaffale su una g dio in una
grande distribuzione e da lì abbiamo
detto proviamo a fare una start up
proviamo a vedere se riusciamo a pensare
dei prodotti che dallo scarto generano
una cosa nuova e lo proponiamo le stesse
realtà che hanno l'eccellenza e il
ticchettio dov'è finito
non c'è più perché ho capito tutto sono
illuminate
no no ad esempio ho smesso di usare di
comprare le bottiglie di plastica
dell'acqua da forse due mesi perché io
sono una dipendente cronica ad acqua
gasata e
sono entrata in casa casa nuova con il
classico attacco da sei di bottiglie di
acqua di plastica il figlio del mio
compagno dieci anni mi guarda e dice no
non puoi farlo e io altro che ticchettio
mi sono sentita più piccola di lui
perché aveva ragione e ho trovato il
modo di bere acqua gasata senza per
forza prendere dalle bottiglie di
plastica in questo momento ticchettio
nella testa non c'è però non è detto che
non torni tra mezz'ora
magari ogni tanto è capitato anche a voi
quello che mi sforzo di fare quando
sento questo ticchettio strano e
fermarmi ascoltarlo dargli spazio e
vedere dove mi porta
[Applauso]